were you allowed visitors when you're in
that lock down yes my husband was there
all the time this guy that's right here
today this guy who's also my T manager
that's fantastic so he's here to support
you he's amazing how did you guys meet
we met we've been together 13 years
we've been married for three and we met
at the food festival that they have once
a year in La called The Taste LA because
it is put on by the LA Times he used to
work at the times and so when we were
dating being on the road so much it was
like a long-distance relationship for
too long
and then we had a conversation and I
said do you think you could like would
you want to be my tour manager I think
you could do it and then I had my good
friend we were discussing her before
Susie Orman the money lady who used to
have a show denied your friend approved
you know and she actually did the job
interview and she said yeah I think you
guys should do it the job for being a
tour manager not not your husand no he
was already pass well we were still
boyfriend and girlfriend that time but
yeah so we go on the road together and
it's great and we laugh and have fun and
find fun places to eat and every Show's
different as we both know boy he has
seen a lot though too much it is a lot I
know you know uh relationships are tough
as it is I know uh I've been married for
a long time and there're ups and downs
but that's you've got some pretty dark
stories young lady dark I know and the
dichotomy between who you are and what
you've gone through and the joy and the
happiness and the lightness that you
spread is wonderful but kind of speaks
to uh you know what comedy that's why
the tragedy and the comedy masks are so
close together when you go to a like a
theater yeah I'm the two masks you
probably are have days when you feel
like you are and many of the comics I
know are many of the actors I know are
as well did you say anything that you're
worried about yeah Randy Randy Randy
you're around for all this hey what was
it what was the question he wasn't list
you're not watching the show listen to
the show I've heard her talk about this
am I in trouble for anything I said no
okay okay you're okay with everything
she said absolutely You're a Good Man
Randy you've been through a lot you're
really supportive that's what the
partnership should be yeah yeah well
it's you know life with Kathy Griffin
ups and downs and you just scroll with
it and the bottom line is she always
makes me laugh so that's part of come on
look you the world now is going
on
he